Hello everyone!
Hey guys!
Oh my god!
Oh, I could hear myself.
I have too many tabs of this.
Is this thing on?
Yeah, hello everybody!
Hello!
Welcome to the press conference!
The Dokey Dokey's press conference!
Very official.
Yeah, very, very, very official.
What could the announcement be?
Oh my god!
It could be anything!
Everything!
What you're thinking of right now?
Yeah, yeah, raw answers only.
What do you guys think it's going to be?
The announcement is like Doki's back to take care of her
child.
Like...
Yeah, which one of us is pregnant, guys?
You got to guess.
What is it?
I'm going to be a grandfather!
Oh, my God!
That's the announcement!
I don't know if I can say that.
That's not the announcement, that's not the announcement, by
the way.
She's a tad bit wild, girl.
Boost her up a little bit.
Sound guy.
No one's ever said that before.
All right, turn up your child's volume.
All right, let me give...
Let me...
Let me lower her mic a little bit.
Sorry, this is her first press conference, so...
I can reach it.
All right, let me...
Don't worry, I'll...
Don't worry, I'll lower...
There you go.
Very good.
Now the mic is closer to her mouth now.
Oh, I can, oh my, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah.
We're very nervous about this announcement.
Whatever it could be.
It could be anything.
We could be, it could be because I got custody of Cheapy
now.
Yeah, I won the lawsuit.
I, I, today was her last day with her mom.
I finally did it.
I won the lawsuit.
That's why she was spending so much time with her mom today
Yeah, it was a good time.
I'm excited to be with my dad today.
I figured it was a work day We're doing a press conference.
Yeah.
Just to announce that or or what else could it be TV?
What could their actual announcement be?
It could be it it it could it.
Oh, it could check.
Give me some ideas.
is you should know what the announcement is we had a
briefing we had a briefing just out it could be a cruise oh
you're right oh yeah yeah so remember how northern lion
canceled his cruise a few days ago so the crews reached out
to us because they need a backup you know and they're like
who else could you reach out to so what did they say what
did they say tv i was called you dokey too because it's like
dokey dokey that was my father's name sorry donkey junior
now that i have custody of you donkey junior what what did
these tell us when they all gave us this offer oh well they
had a big discount because you know they were gonna give it
to northern lion but they were like i know these two
rebounds yeah you know discount because we have it ready you
know so we got it nice and cheap yeah we got nice and cheap
so we're gonna have the the dokey dokey uh cruise now
instead of the north it's gonna be everything that northern
lion was was gonna provide but then they were they're just
gonna like write dokey dokey and then stick like and tape it
over northern lion like yeah like duct tape cardboard on the
side yeah yeah because that's gonna go so well all of us
trapped on the cruise anything can have anything can happen
in the ocean you know and awesome well I mean it could be
something else though it could be something else what else
could it be what else could the announcement be um we could
be like you know opening uh cryptocurrency oh my god yes
remember that they told us the yeah the dope oh i should do
have a jokie coin right out right now yeah i do have a jokie
coin and let's collab oh my god we should do a we should do
a crypto collab yeah and then we'll get a rug pull like
right yeah yeah yeah okay yeah yeah yeah we're gonna pull
the rug oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah don't worry our mic is my
our mics are muted okay so so um all right okay i just gotta
be sure we're on like the same page on the rug pulling part
yeah all right okay and anyway guys yes the very legitimate
cryptocurrency that cheapy and i are both working on um
that's gonna be live in 30 minutes it's exciting guys it's
so exciting as you all know both of our own individual
crypto coins are doing very well um almost as good as
bitcoin if you think about it bye bye to the moon we go uh
yeah yeah remember the last three digits of your credit oh
i'm so excited i'm so excited oh my gosh she's so excited
about her crypto coin look at her go see this is why i won
the custody battle yeah what exactly what i heard she had
when i heard about her crypto coin i had to i had to make
sure my money no no no i just thought that that is my kid
you know All those amazing ideas that she had, like, you
know how I had a cryptocurrency, you have a cryptocurrency.
I was like, I don't need a DNA test.
She is my child.
She is.
Yes.
I finally accepted her as Joki Jr. Like father, like son.
Oh my gosh.
But the situation is crazy.
But maybe announcement is something else.
You know what maybe it could be something else.
Maybe there's a third dope.
We're introducing a third doki in the Yeah, yeah, yeah,
we're about to in 30 minutes We're gonna have the newest
member to the doki doki club a third potential doki Yes You
need a father son and the Holy Spirit.
Oh my god now my son is coming to join Oh my god, yeah, it's
like, you know, have you ever played Neopets, Chibi?
Yes, yes, yes.
You know how it's like the Neopet and then the Pet, the Pet
Pet, Pet, and then the Pet, Pet, Pet.
So you're my Pet pet, so you're going to have a little pet
pet, the little flea guy.
Well, I'm your son and your pet.
Yeah, yeah, and then you're going to have your very own pet,
too.
Yay!
Let's go!
I'll take it.
Listen, if it gets you to call me more than just on
weekends, I ate like once a month.
That'd be awesome, dude.
I need more time with my dad.
Chibi, don't you remember?
I won the custody battle.
Yeah.
We don't need to call each other.
Or you don't have to call me anymore.
We're going to be together on this.
You're going to live with me now.
Really?
Yeah.
That could be the announcement in 30 minutes.
That could be...
I promise I won't piss on the carpet a minute.
But in 30 minutes, we're going to find out if Chibi is going
to live with me For the custody battle, we should start a
streamer house Because that always goes well for content
creation We should get like those like $100 million mansions
in LA Yeah, yeah, yeah, and then have like five Lamborghinis
in a garage And then, yeah, yeah, and then get funded by
Phase Clan Yeah, Faze Clan's gonna pick up YouTubers.
That could be the announcement.
Faze Clan is gonna sign us.
It could be.
What could it be?
There's so many endless possibilities.
Doki Doki is joining Faze Clan.
It could be TSM.
Wait, no, TSM's broke.
I don't think TSM could afford us, even though we're not
that expensive.
I was not pretty cheap.
I'll be honest.
Where, like, you can give Cheevy a little...
I'll take a McChicken.
Yeah, a little Capri Sun and then McChicken.
Ooh!
My only...
Dude, I love Capri Suns.
Oh, my God.
It's only, like, two slurps and then it's dry.
That's true.
It's like, it's like a one pump, you know?
It's like a made-for-children or something.
Yeah, yeah.
One pump chump.
It's alright, Cheevy.
Someone will love you.
Why do you say that as if you don't love me?
I mean...
No, no, no.
Other than me.
Really?
Yeah, yeah, of course.
Why also did I invite you to the press conference, Chibi?
Come on.
They need to look good to like the court so you- No, no, no,
of course.
Come on, sit here, Chibi.
Wait, let me make- Come on, Chibi.
Everything's gonna be fine.
Let me- Here, you can sit- You can sit on my lap.
There you go.
Wait, really?
Look at that.
That could be the announcement.
We're starting to bond as a family.
I'm a siss on her now.
I'm like, I'm moving.
Like those, like those, you know, like those angler fishes?
We're like the, yeah, yeah.
Like the, the, the male is like a dried up husk physically
attached to the, to the female angler fish.
Yeah.
I'm going to suck your life.
I don't think the male angler fish is wearing the pants.
I hear.
Well, I can't hear you right now.
I'm opening to your skin.
Yes.
So that thing, I'm gonna suck the life force out of my son.
I bet.
No!
And then she starts drying up into a husk, like evaporating.
Shuck my wig off.
Yum.
Oh, it tastes like cotton candy.
Spit it out.
It's gonna be wet now.
Look, I got a new wig.
No!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I'm so nervous, though, Chibi.
Are you nervous?
We've been.
I am nervous.
It's a really, really big announcement, and no one has
guessed what it is.
No one has guessed.
Yeah, or maybe.
Unless I think we missed it.
I'm pretty sure.
It could be any of it.
It could be multiple things.
Actually, one person guessed it right now.
It could be anything.
We could be announcing, like, maybe a merch collab.
We have a merch collab.
It could be that.
On collab, it could be anything.
No, it couldn't be either of those.
Or it couldn't be either of those.
Or it could be all of those.
And it could be nothing.
It could be nothing.
It could be the late April Fool's trick that we delayed to
today.
Oh, yeah, get April 21st in.
Yeah, get April 21st.
It's almost like April 1st.
But because there's two of us, we put a two in front of the
one.
Yeah, so 21.
The two represents...
yeah exactly you might be getting pranked right now yeah you
could got him we will be announcing the announcement if you
give dokeeper 10 000 through super chat so if you want to
get that going oh my oh yeah and then you also have to gift
uh thousand subs on chibi's channel as well as long and when
you unlock the it's like a side but you know like the the
main quest line yeah the main quest line if you want to
progress the main quest line you gotta Remember to do these
two very simple tasks to unlock the announcement and
progress the story It's like hangman for every thousand
dollars you can guess a letter and we'll like we'll pick it
off if it is Wouldn't be funny we actually told you guys
what it was but you guys just didn't believe us Yeah one of
the things we said was true yeah what if we yeah one of the
thing what if one of the Things we said was true oh what if
what if we're doing an outfit together where we're sinking
up Like, the moment, the moment it hits 4 p.m., we both
debut the outfit right here at the press conference.
It could be that one.
10 truths and 10 lies and one truth.
Guess which one's the lie?
Guess which one's the truth?
Oh, my God, I like this one.
What if we're starting a new YouTuber company, but only
Doki's are allowed to join?
If you're That is so good And you have a battle royale To
find out who the real Doki Yeah Can the real Doki please
stand up The number one Doki The number That's such Do you
think there's other Doki's album?
There has to be I'm pretty sure There are other Only Doki's
can apply to this company Doki Corp Real That's right That's
right Oh my god Doki Doki Vtuber Club I like that's really
good that's good and then all the and then we do a dokey
collab and then we just call each other dokeys and we have
to figure out like who would you play among us yeah and all
of us are dokey yeah yeah we'd be like dokey is sus it's
dokey she's the imposter and you have to figure out which
dokey it is and because we can't say anything else but dokey
oh yes that'd actually
dokeys together.
Yeah, we'll have a giant tournament.
That giant dokey tournament.
One dokey to rule them all.
To crown like, it's like, it's like Game of Thrones, you
know, like they're trying to figure out who's the guy who's
the, I never watched Game of Thrones, but this is my
assumption.
The, I assume that they're trying to figure out who's gonna
be the guy who sits on the throne that unites all.
Because what the fuck is up with, yeah.
Yeah.
exactly it's the game of thrones so then uh we're gonna try
to decide which dokey it would sit on the third the dokey
throne to rule all the dokeys construct the throne like they
sit oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and then we sit on the other
dokeys yeah yeah yeah yeah so every time a dokey gets
eliminated they become part of the throne right they become
like a leg or yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and you
don't want to lose first because then whoever loses first
has to be the seat the seat warmer oh no i guess i gotta be
sad on oh no oh gosh darn it i what if what if we have like
a collaboration with like an amusement park and they're
doing like a themed dokey dokey amusement park land for us
dude they could have a roller coaster in the shape my spine.
Oh my god.
And like the tracks are your spine that's going like.
Yeah.
And you can be the cart.
I'll be the cart and that's just
That'd be awesome.
I mean it might be obviously because it might be real.
Oh my god.
It could be real.
What if we're literally describing it right now?
What if.
Chibi what if we're doing a maid cafe together?
Oh my god.
We'd have no customers.
That would not be a good idea.
We both spill drinks on everyone.
Yeah, but then they'll be like, oh, they're so...
They're so ditsy and clumsy.
Oh my god.
You think it would work?
Yeah.
Well, no, because I'd be pissed off because they'd only
request you.
They'd be like, no, no, no.
It's a package deal.
So it's like, buy one, get one free, you know?
It's like one plus one.
So they can't refund you.
So they have to, like, you have to be there.
You just showed up with me equipped on your shoulders.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Exactly, exactly.
like i'm sorry i can get behind that yeah yeah see so what
do you mean you can get behind it we are doing it what are
you talking about oh yeah guys um here's the amount spent 20
minutes early we are remember when we saw the artwork too
the artwork together like a couple of days ago less than the
maid outfits those are so cute you should have seen the maid
outfit uh on shivi it was really buff guy so it looked
really good on the oh yeah yeah she has like yeah yeah she
has like two versions of it the one where like she's like
super buff and the one word like her now basically oh okay
what food did you choose for the maid cafe oh I I decided on
chicken nuggets oh the dino oh the dino nuggies I remember
yeah yeah yeah so her her maid cafe food is the dino nuggets
with the caprice and remember when we were talking about
caprice that's when talking about the enough.
It was the head.
Yeah, that was it.
We were talking about the Capri Sun.
So um, so that's what we were talking.
Mine's um, mine was like those, you know those like, uh,
what are they called?
Like those like pre-heat meals, the hungry man.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's literally the kids ones.
Yeah.
No, mine's the hungry man.
So, uh, yeah.
So it's like basically like uh those like pre-cooked at the
tv dinners like those pre-cooked meals where it's like the
steak ones and with the with the sauce yeah with the sauce
and the the potatoes and uh the mashed potatoes yeah yeah
yeah green beans yeah yeah so that's mine so that's my uh my
meal yeah and also be like my like a microwave one too so
microwave muggies oh yeah yeah the correct dynamo nuggies
too mine have my comes with beer like the one in a can yeah
yeah yeah it comes with a can of beer from bud light my dad
would like come to the cafe and choose your meal dude i am
your dad what do you mean oh oh oh you mean you mean paul
you know yeah yeah yeah my step down yeah yeah yeah wait
they got married i thought it was just uh no he's just kind
of like a i don't know i i started calling him dad oh but
but like only because you know he's you know like hanging
out with my mom a lot yeah i have another kid so they don't
mess up with like how they did with me and you know i'm
sorry i should i should have told you this off stream i'm
sorry my bad i mean but you don't mean it right no i only
say to make That's fine, you know, he needs it, you know?
Yeah, because really it's secure because you're, like, a
lot, like, obviously, I mean, you saw me and you ride that
motorcycle, you know what I picked you up from your mom's
place?
Like, you know, he was intimidated by that, wasn't he, when
I came over on the motorcycle?
Yeah, he was wearing open toe shoes with sand, with socks.
Oh, yeah, I remember that.
Yeah, yeah, I remember that.
But it's her, it's, you know, it's, you know, He needs a
win, you know, he needs- Yeah, I'm just trying to boost his
confidence.
Of course, of course, of course.
See, so, see, I mean, Paul's not doing this maid cafe with
you.
Yeah, yeah, what does he do for you?
Yeah, I mean, I mean, what would your mom's boyfriend, you
know?
Like, you know, I still have to give him a little bit of
respect.
Yeah, that's what your mom would have wanted, you know?
But I wish you were on a first-name basis with me, you know?
What do you mean, Doki Jr?
I just feel like, you know, you just call me, ah, the pink
rat, or like, all the scoliosis.
No, of course not.
I would never say that in front of you.
Oh, just, okay, I thought I heard him say it once, so that
makes me...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I would never say that in front of you.
Okay, okay, cool.
I thought I overgrew it once.
Oh, it must have been a sneeze.
You know, sometimes, you know, whenever I sneeze, it sounds
like...
like you know yeah oh my god that was a big one that was a
big one yeah yeah yeah sneezes sneezes go crazy and i can't
really judge somebody's sneeze you know we taught you chibi
you can't don't judge people by how they sneeze and
everything maybe you're not smooth that we're partnering
with musinex that's right we're the new mascots oh my god
yes what if we're in it gonna be in a We're gonna be in the
next gotcha game.
What if that's the announcement?
I would play the frick out of that.
What do you mean?
We did.
We demoed it.
Oh yeah, we play tested it.
Yeah, we play tested it like a few days ago, do you
remember?
That's why, yeah.
Yeah, that's why.
That was really, really good.
That's why I had to fly out on Friday and Saturday.
Like I was play testing the game.
They wanted us, yeah, they wanted us to be at the studio.
So they invited us to studio to play play test uh the new
game where we're gonna be in and oh my god can't wait to
show you guys the the the video trailer oh i remember that
video trailer voice acting it was so hard right it was so
hard and we actually did all the stunts too like oh yeah the
motion capture yeah all the stunts oh yeah that's crazy i
had to like throw chibi up into the air and then hope to god
she would land on her feet yep yeah it was really really
cool it was really hard to do because we we didn't have any
stunt doubles yeah and like we had to try that multiple
times because she kept missing so i have a couple bruises i
do have broken leg right now but it's worth it because you
guys want to see the trailer yeah and and the studio comped
her broken leg too good thing they had insurance you know
they they paid for her bill at the hospital i was able to
visit her at the hospital because you know i i was really i
was really busy get well card from walmart didn't even sign
it or anything still had the receipt but it was cool yeah
yeah because like i was gonna sign it later you know tight
you know so like I was just yeah it was I couldn't find a
pen what was I supposed to do I know no one no one had a pen
like what was I supposed to do about that you didn't even
sign my cast either so you really do need to find a pen like
yeah I know like nobody carries pens anymore is that crazy I
just feel like oh yeah we should go to Penn Island and then
maybe maybe we'll be able to these days no one even like
it's somewhere it's somewhere deep in the ocean and they
remember they i'm surprised nobody found it yet the last pen
on in on earth yeah every dude it's it's sound but you know
i i am healing i'm getting better and i think the trailer
will make it worth it because you guys are gonna lose your
mind yeah such a freaking good game i know yes oh hey fanda
oh my god fanda is here oh my god oh thank you because they
know about the announcement they know what Yeah, yeah, they
know about the announcement.
Yeah, the announcement is that we're working with Bandai.
Bandai, why are you here early?
You're supposed to be here like in 10 minutes, Bandai.
Wait, you know, like the intern on that counter is like, Oh,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait It was just a bit.
Your honor, it was a bit.
Fanta's like, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Yeah, we're on Sword Art.
The announcement is that we are in Sword Art Online.
That's it.
Bro, I used to love that anime when I was a kid.
Season 1 was so good.
I never actually got a chance to watch it.
I just always heard all the memes about Storydart Online
because he had like, because of the, you know, the sister.
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
Yep, I'm well aware.
I'm well aware of that.
Sister.
Well, technically, they're...
Oh, technically, you want to be technical about it.
I'm just going off of what happened.
It's honestly not that bad of an anime.
Like, the fighting is so...
I know the animation.
is really good in general.
Yeah, and the music is good, too.
Yeah, like, I know the opening.
The opening was really catchy.
And, like, Sword Art Online basically, like, kick-started,
like, the Isakai genre.
Yeah, kind of.
Yeah.
I think I was, like, the...
Well, I wonder if it was the first one I ever watched of
that genre.
I'll have to go back and, like, think about it.
I'm...
Because it was that or the other one with the mains, the two
mains?
What were they called?
The Rees-ero?
Was it Rees- Oh, my God!
That was one of the first in- It's either that or Rizira.
I've never I was a degenerate as a kid.
I didn't know it was like Gooner.
I just thought it was like That's funny.
It's funny the way she shows her pants.
I love I just I love the design.
I think that's why like She's She's the reason I love pink
hair.
Oh the pink Hair one or not the blue hair.
I thought the blue hair One was more popular.
Oh the blue hair is like the dragon girl.
A dragon?
Wait she can turn Into a dragon?
She like has She's like she's like really smart and shy.
Oh I don't hate what's her name the the freaking maid I
can't stand her Oh my god stop I I can't stand her Which one
Which one oh my god guys 10 more minutes till the
announcement Oh wait I was thinking about zero Louise Oh You
said zero and I was thinking zero to describe her No wait
which one came first Which one came first That's the one I
have I'm so confused It's not that good.
I haven't watched either before.
I'm so confused.
I just accept whatever she be saying That was one of the
first anime I ever watched and I have like all of the manga.
I read that motherfucker in public in I was 12 years old
reading that manga.
Wait, are you even allowed to have that manga?
I remember when I was 12.
I knew I was like, dude, it's you're no disguise, but you're
like, dude, oh my god, that one is the first like, I think
like one of the first anime besides gosh I ever watched.
Someone was like, wait, but then the person in that manga
doesn't even turn into a dragon either.
Who turns into a dragon?
No, she doesn't turn into a dragon.
I don't think she has a dragon.
Oh, she has.
Okay.
I'm just like, who is it?
Who turns into a dragon?
Dude, I have like the first like 10 chapters of the manga
because I loved it so much as a kid, dude.
Oh my god.
I think my first manga was Death Note.
I was like super normy.
I watched it for the first time.
Oh, you watched, oh yeah, the whole, did you understand all
the memes now after watching it?
Yes, I do.
I do.
And I, it's a shame there was only a first half of that
anime, it's a big show.
Oh yeah, that's it.
I'm so, like, Nier was my favorite, or N was my favorite
character in Death Note.
Like he was my favorite, but then the anime butchered the
hell out of him.
I was so sad about it.
Because I love the orphanage kids, like the orphans, like N,
Meadow, and Mac.
I didn't like the second half, but I really liked that
character, N I thought was really cool.
But like everything else around it, I was like...
Yeah, but it's the manga does it more justice.
Have you seen this?
I figured.
Yeah, the manga does it more...
Oh, we did the Techno Killer with N.
Don't worry that I actually...
I played it on stream with a bunch of other VTubers.
It's really silly, because you're trying to find out who's
Kira.
I saw some people playing that.
Yeah, yeah.
And then you can like you can like exchange Kira books
between people and then just start writing crazy Like just
start writing everybody's names.
It's really really fun Um, I went back and watched a bunch
of anime I never watched when it was popular like I watched
I think it was like I binge watched death note and attack on
Titan in like the same month And I was like nah, I missed
that on it was like pretty much a pretty fun anime You know
what's right?
I thought before like I watched attack on Titan.
I thought it was a comedy because Because I mean it is to do
a best No, no, okay, because like it was around the time of
Tumblr and then everybody was posting the gifts of the
titans just running around And then there was a tight the
cart titans Yeah, no, just this like no, it's just like the
regular titans just running and then somebody put a mute
like put us I'm so happy Like that song Yeah, they put if
they put the I like I'm so happy like on the titan running
and I was like oh that's fucking hilarious I should watch
this oh yeah we're gonna have a cameo on attack on the from
the studios who made attack on titan that was our segue
we're gonna have like we're gonna have a cameo we're working
with the studio who made attack on titan and you're gonna
include both of us we have voice acting roles in there We're
so excited.
We're going to be showing you guys a trailer in six minutes
in six minutes for whatever our announcement is.
That's right.
It's going to be a comedy as well.
Oh, yeah.
Now that's going to be a comedy.
They're like, what do you know, like those long ass titles
in for like anime and stuff like like two VTubers got stuck,
got Isakai into a fantasy world where they both turn into
Titans now are now trying to find their way back to Earth.
right yeah yeah it's like that time i that time two vtubers
were reconstructed into titans and they just want to go back
to playing together and having a happy father-son
relationship without eating people that'd be really good i
would watch that i would watch that what if we learned that
we love eating people and then we want to like i mean i mean
what's so wrong about that you know what's wrong with that
yeah we have rights like i'm so glad we do i i'm so glad we
have right thank god we have showed out to having to tighten
rights guys represent we have five minutes oh my god five
more minutes oh i think we actually sort of said the
announcements out of all the We technically we sort of said
it now.
It's just up to you guys to figure out which one's the right
one
It's one of them So what is the you're gonna find out in
five minutes This is an ARG now We're gonna show it in four
five minutes.
We're gonna show you guys coordinates of what of the
treasure we buried in yeah it's somewhere in the world and
in five minutes we're gonna show you guys the coordinates to
the first clue of whatever we buried in whatever country it
is and it's up to you guys yeah it's in a geocache in the
middle of a forest but which forest it's up to you guys to
find out is in the house in It's like we buried it with the
One Piece.
Like, oh yeah, we're good friends with the One Piece guy.
I started watching One Piece.
I'm 40 episodes into it.
I'm, like, halfway done.
Oh, shit.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
You're very close, I think.
I think, like, I think you're, like, 10 episodes away from
finishing.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, I'm excited.
So, one of my favorite characters, Sanji, is pretty cool.
Oh, yeah.
I heard, like, wasn't there a thing where the...
word like they're trying to like what's the word trying to
give Sanji less of an important role or something did you
read about that?
Did they find out he's one of my favorites?
Yeah they were like it's Stevie's favorite we gotta delete
the character yeah I like Sanji too I actually I like his
design I like his design and his penciled on eyebrows pretty
cool oh my god did you see oh did you see there were like
video clips of like the official like Sanji meeting
character in in universal and yeah yeah they do such a good
job because like they're not afraid to be cringe yeah like
they're doing the acrobat and then like when he sees a guy
he's like yeah actually i saw the video there he like he
sees a guy comes up to him he's like don't talk to me and
then he goes to the girl he goes to the girl's like oh melee
like beautiful women
bookmarking the video on twitter because i was like i wanted
to show my my chat it's like he actually stays in character
and everything i love when like i love that like people can
be silly and not get judged i love that oh my god i know
like like you're like so true to the character as well yeah
i remember there's one oh my god it's too i'm so nervous i'm
so i can't believe i can't believe there's two minutes left
wait oh my god Okay, I have to get the picture out for this,
too.
I'm getting it ready.
I'm getting...
Oh, oh, oh.
One minute.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
One minute.
I'm so freaking scared.
Yeah, and then we end stream at the moment.
It's...
It was an April Fool's Prank.
Got him.
Oh, I'm so nervous, TV.
We both worked so hard on this for so long.
And I can't believe we're finally revealing whatever the
fuck this is that we've been baiting you guys with.
Get ready to end stream.
Get ready.
Yeah, yeah, I'm getting ready.
My finger is hovering the end button.
Oh, my God.
This April Fool's Prank, I can't believe we're finally doing
this.
prank all right oh you're about to find out which one of us
is pregnant oh
oh oh look at the clock look at the clock it's still 359 for
me oh oh oh um so one of us is not start our clocks are it's
okay it's daylight savings time it's daylight my phone says
59 my computer says yeah i think your computer got fucked
over with daylight.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh,
oh, oh.
I wasn't ready for how big it's Doki Doki rewind time.
Yes.
All right.
For those who are confused, what the fuck this is?
It's a sticker.
It's merch.
All right, so for those who are confused, it is a concert.
It's a concert with Doki and Doki.
But it's not just a regular concert.
It's gonna, it's, oh my gosh, I'm, I, I, fuck, I'm, okay.
So anyway, for those who are like, oh my gosh, I already
posted a link to tickets because it went live right now.
But for those who are wondering, oh my gosh, you got tickets
now.
I have to buy tickets now.
we are doing phase one and phase two there will be phase two
round of tickets uh for next week so don't worry don't worry
about being like oh my god to get him now there will be more
tickets releasing uh next week and we're looking into
getting uh streaming tickets so for those who are uh can't
travel uh do not worry so i just want to calm you guys down
i want to calm you guys down before like everybody was like
i gotta go i gotta go yeah so there will be there we're
working on streaming tickets too so there is all right so
doki doki rewind time this concert is not just your regular
like like vtuber concert or like idol concert the reason why
it's called rewind time is because chibi and i we are
focusing on songs english songs it's all It's all English
songs, right?
It's all English songs.
And we're focusing on songs from 2000s to 2010.
So, so, um, yeah, we're looking at nostalgic area.
Uh, we have, we have punk rock songs.
We have punk songs.
Uh, we have punk pop.
We have emo.
We have like, uh...
A couple memes in there, too.
We have some memes from the early 2000s to 2010.
So it's a throwback concert.
Yes.
So...
Grab your bracelets, your bands, your, uh, your sport bands,
your fringe hairs, your, your black shirts, your scene
clothing, your cargo, cargo pants.
Uh, I won't, but I don't want to feel old.
It's not feeling old, guys.
It's nostalgic.
We're here.
them have fun anyway so we're so excited there are a lot of
guests it's not just gonna be chibi and i we have let me
count it real quick there's a lot of guests that will be
here that will be singing either duets uh or group songs
some guests are singing more than one songs in this concert
so there's let me count including your guests too so there's
one two three four five Six, seven...
Six, seven.
I'm just gonna pull up.
I'm just gonna pull up the set list.
Let me pull up.
I actually lost count.
I was like, there's so many.
There's a lot of amazing VTubers that are participating in
this conscious scene with us as well.
Alright, let me grab the set list real quick.
I actually forgot how many feet there's because we have so
many feet joining us so a lot of our friends are joining us
and it's gonna be super exciting let me pull up the set list
now because I actually forgot how many people because I we
invited a lot of people to join us it is it is it's a party
it's oh yes and it's gonna be a live band so we are singing
with a live band that will be at the venue as well so it's
not just like not like um playing from just the instrumental
but you guys might see that it's day one day two day three
uh chibi and that were day three so uh our guests are like
this is our own concert outside of the fantastic reality but
it is presented by fantastic reality so they helped us with
uh Co-producing all of it and organizing everything.
So I know there's like other guests on day one and day two
But we won't be overlapping with them.
Our concert will also be on my birthday It's sort of like a
birthday concert chibi-doki is my very special guest for my
birthday concert and yeah, and I I helped with Figure out I
may I came up with the title the theme and the direction of
this concert so I came up with the name Doki Doki Rewind
Time because originally it was, at first, it would be Doki
Squared Rewind Time but then I thought like Doki Doki, like
Doki Doki Literature Club.
Yeah, it sounded a lot better than I did at this stuff.
So, but for those who are wondering, I will be doing that
stream other than the birthday concert for those who are
like, who are like, oh, what about like your own birthday
stream?
Don't worry, there will be a second, stream after the
concert because this concert is in the afternoon type deal
so um but yes and a reason why i said rewind time is because
i was thinking about you know how will smith was like oh
yeah it's rewind you know what he said that on the youtube
rewind he's like oh yeah it's It's Rewind Time.
We need a B-Tuber Rewind.
Yeah, yeah, we need a, yes, exactly.
It's a B-Tuber Rewind, also B-Tuber Rewind.
Also, B-Tuber Rewind, that's hot.
That's hot, that's hot.
It's Rewind Time.
That's right, Will Smith is gonna be- Yeah, Will Smith might
be here.
Might be here.
Good disclaimer, he will not be at the concert.
Please do not.
He'll be there with Band-Aid.
Yeah.
We have like a, the little cutout, like, you know those like
B-Tuber cutouts?
He was like a little at the front of the concert.
Yeah, and he's like, and he's like, he has no, yet there's
no relations between Will Smith and this concert.
Someone just happened to left the Will Smith cutout in front
of the...
Like a Hatsune Miku, like a hologram of him.
Oh, that...
Yeah.
That'd be awesome.
So, um, oh yeah, I was trying to grab, uh, but yeah, this is
Chibi's first 3D concert as well.
It is a 3D concert for those who are watching.
wondering yes it is tv's first 3d concert we have to say
about it while trying to find the set list real quick i'm
kind of nervous i'm gonna trip and fall and or like burp on
stage on accident i i literally i have no stage presence
aura i i was in theater once and the one play i was in was a
comedy and no one laughed true story yep but people are
laughing now i know but they're gonna laugh when i like fall
on the pavement they're gonna laugh when i forget i go i go
line Yeah, but we're laughing with you, you know, you can,
we're gonna, you start humming, you know, be like, cool.
Yeah, and then they'll never know.
They'll never know.
All right, wait, I got the set list.
All right, let me count how many guests are there.
Okay, there's one, two, three, four, five, uh, six, seven,
eight.
Around eight guests or seven.
I might have miscounted because we all...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So around seven to eight guests will be part of this
concert.
And like I said, some of the guests have more than one or
more than one song that's going to be singing with us.
There's group songs, there's duets.
And it's going to be very exciting.
We will be announcing guests at a later time.
I don't know what the plan is regarding like we're
announcing all of them at once.
But remember, okay, but for our tickets, our tickets are on
day three, by the way.
That's our dokey dokey rewind time.
It's going to be, we are...
And we do our best to have the screening tickets as well.
Yeah, yeah.
We do our best.
Yeah, it's currently being worked out.
At the moment, we really wanted to have streaming tickets.
So we're currently working on it, and we hope to have more
information regarding streaming tickets soon.
And for those who are also wondering, We will be uploading
on our channels a for those who can't afford it, either
traveling to the concert or buying a streaming ticket.
We will be uploading one performance.
I don't know if it's like from each of us or it's just one,
but we will be uploading a performance after the concert.
So this is something we requested for, we asked for.
So it's for people who can't afford it.
know can't travel there will be uploading one performance
for everybody um and also uh this was also something that uh
i requested as well where i wanted uh um i wanted to have a
phase two of tickets because uh originally um originally
they wanted to uh they wanted to have all tickets on sold
today but then we requested to have phase one and phase two
so that people who can't make this announcement you know or
time zones or something um they didn't see it they have
especially vip tickets as well especially vip tickets uh we
are planning next week to have more tickets release if uh if
there's like you know if vip tickets sold out already before
next week we are releasing more next week on tuesday at uh 4
p.m pst so just wanted to let you guys uh know for those who
Oh, it's Matara here.
Hey, Matara.
Matara will be on day one.
Apparently, people are seeing people.
They already leaked some of the VTubers.
No, Kisan, Lily, Pichu, and Matara are on day one.
They're not part of Chibi and I's concert, which is day
three.
They also have their own special guests as well.
So, Matara, Kisan, and Lily Pichu all have their own special
guests for day one.
For Chibi and I, we have our special guests for our guests.
concert on day three so those haven't been announced yeah
it's gonna be awesome there's like oh my god i'm so i'm so
nervous we've been both of us have been so stressed out
leading up uh leading up to it um well i was i was talking
to doki about this before she went live i was like i was
very personally heard her sing and I like went to her
channel and stalked her music and I was like this
motherfucker has an angelic voice and I sound like a
freaking oh my god is that true like a traveling zombie in
Minecraft I heard an angelic voice I heard your I heard your
demos it was good I heard your practice tracks TV I was good
it was good you were yeah no you guys are not You guys are
oh my god the songs that she be and I gonna sing together
you guys are not gonna you guys won't be like Yes, the
songs.
Oh, yeah, like I basically I basically I sort of hand picked
the entire set list for all of us Because like we had to
make sure we can get the songs approved because it had to be
approved for Streaming wise to find a lot of good ones.
Yeah, yeah, so best ones possible So I made like a giant
list of songs to get rights checked and everything for this
concert and then like the songs that chibi and i picked for
our duets it's so it's you guys are not a favorite i can't
say what it is but i think you guys will know what it is
when it comes out it's so good it's it is really good it is
really good it's so good i was like we gotta sing this and
we gotta make the choreography the same as this song we were
like it has to be one-to-one the choreo for this exact song
like it would make it all worth it oh we we're walking in
yeah there are literally gonna it's gonna be the best part
i'm so excited oh there is oh wait there is a disney song
it's like there's no disney but i remember there is a disney
song i forgot that Disney I forgot honestly but there are
some a lot of classics it's a lot it's like we wouldn't
during when I was there because I have to travel to to the
studio to like prepare for you know even though the concert
is still a couple months away.
That's why I had to travel.
I had to travel to LA to go over with the team working on
this concert.
And like every time we were prepping for the songs, if they
were all singing like, oh my God, it was always stuck in
their heads because they were all singing along to and
everything.
They kept every time we went through the song, they just
kept singing along.
It's like, oh my God, these songs are just so catchy.
This is a good set list.
So I'm really looking forward to you guys hearing it too.
Yeah, I feel like every song we picked is like one you can
dance to.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And like the best part, I think like the most exciting part
about this concert is just it's, you know, something you
don't really see in B-Tuber concerts, too, as well.
Because like, you know, they're more like idol-like or more
like, more idol-like or more like more recent songs.
But we really wanted to do something like throwback type
deal.
Like, Y2K era, too.
Yeah, and there's a lot of good ones.
Yeah, there is a lot of good.
So, are we doing a mosh fit?
I don't know.
What's the mosh fit?
That's the mosh fit.
Yeah, yeah, like, someone's gonna jump off into the crowd.
There's gonna be crowd surfing as well.
You're like, yeah.
You can get, like, cardboard cutouts of us to throw in the
audience.
Oh, my God.
We should do it.
Actually, that is such a good idea.
Wait, get those giant beach balls, but put one of our
cardboard cutouts.
inside.
Should we like chuck them around?
Well, one of us, most likely you, too.
Just make it my face.
It's most likely you.
Yeah, and then it'll be like, they're crowd surfing.
We're crowd surfing there.
Open up the...
But yeah, so those are like, oh, well, there'll be streaming
tickets.
They are working on that right now.
It's not up on the...
It's not up on the website or anything yet.
But they are working on streaming tickets at the moment.
please do not worry because I know LA at the moment
traveling to LA is very expensive.
I was at LA a couple of days ago and so I do understand.
I do understand.
So we are working on getting streaming tickets for you guys
and you know we wanted this to be an amazing experience for
everybody for all fans, for your Chibi's fans and my fans
for the Dragoons.
What do you call your fans, Chibi?
Because mine's Dragoons.
In South.
No I'm just Okay, I just call them chat.
Chat, chat.
Yeah, so like her chat and the dragons.
We will have merch.
It's going to be online.
It's going to be on site and online.
So if you're going to the venue, you can buy the merch
venue.
If you aren't going to the concert, we will have the merch
online as well.
So look forward to that.
It's going to be amazing.
And it's a good opportunity if you want, if you just want
some merch.
Maybe you're not into concerts.
There's going to be some cool stuff to grab for sure.
Yeah, there's a lot of cool stuff.
Very on, I will say, they're very on theme for merch.
I can't say exactly what the merch are, but they're very on
theme to what we are doing.
So they're not typical.
They're very different.
Yeah, they're not typical like VTuber merch.
It's more so like, you know, and a concert type merch type
deal.
Yeah.
Um, what other, do you, is there anything else, anything
else to talk about for the, the concert?
Anything that's a talk about?
Um, I, I, I'm just really freaking excited and nervous,
because I, I've never done anything like this before.
And so, Doki's done such an amazing job, uh, like, like
pulling the strings behind literally everything.
She's been, you guys don't even, she won't say it, but she's
been working so freaking hard, guys.
Like, like, unbelievably hard.
So even if you can't, uh, see it, uh, please, please,
please, uh, send her your support.
And if you can, just check it out, share it with your
friends.
And we're both very, very excited.
And she worked so unbelievably hard, like so crazy.
I really appreciate that.
You worked so hard to, especially everything you've been
going through, like the voice.
Like, because you know about how, like, your chat knows
about your voice.
That's come, the voice issues lately.
It sucks because, like, the second, like, we were getting
the, like, the wheels turning on this, I could not speak.
And so Doki has been so patient with me and the whole team
has to with everything.
Because, for those who don't know, I was, like, really,
really bad.
I have chronic throat problems because I don't shut the
fridge.
up in my job if you can call this a job in my hobby and uh
it got so bad like during recording time that it was really
hard but we pushed through it and i'm doing a lot better now
and uh because of doki's kindness and the team's kindness we
were able to get through it so i'm really really excited
yeah like we're so like everyone has worked so hard i was
really concerned about chibi earlier too because of all the
uh the health issues that she was going i was like chibi
just don't push yourself too hard it's okay if you're yeah
though he was so sweet through everything she was like you
need you need the rest yeah she was like i'm gonna record
i'm gonna record three three songs right now i'm gonna test
i'm gonna i'm gonna do like the demos right now i'm gonna do
like the demo recordings uh of three songs in one day and i
was like you are fucking chibi no chibi just one you can
just they're just scratch audio there's just you just
there's just demos i was just
songs at once.
She's my dad.
She took care of me.
I was like, you're great.
You don't, because I, you know, I've done a lot of these
content before.
I know how much it strains your vocal chords too.
So that's why I was like trying to be like, please, please
pace yourself.
You don't, it's like, these aren't even like the final like
song recordings or anything.
They're just demos and stuff that we need to help the band.
Because we had to, we had to record like demos and stuff for
the band who are playing live by the way for those who
weren't there earlier the band is there in person playing
all these songs live so we had to record like demos scratch
audios for them so they can be sure to time to play timing
to what we're singing and everything so it was crazy the um
it was really crazy but yeah i'm really excited it is like
like i said chibi's like my special guest for this concert
so she has her own little set list too that picked to sing
for all her fans in her chat too.
So, I'm pretty excited.
I saw, I like, I think my favorite is your solo song.
Like, yeah.
Yeah, your solo song.
You like that one?
I thought it was perfect.
It's just perfectly silly.
It was, it's a good one.
Also, I will, I will be debuting two new outfits for this
concert.
New 3D outfits.
on theme to this concert um oh but you chibi i know you said
you wanted to earlier but i don't know if you were also
debuting uh i i i well you know i can shave my head and like
put your face on i can like get a tattoo i'm actually
getting dokey bird tattooed on my head yeah yeah when you go
to the concert you're gonna see like my face on her head uh
that's right that's right uh-huh I just hope to I don't I
just hope that you know at least we sell half the tickets
you know 50% I just that's why I just hope we sell like 50%
I just that's just my goal I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm
kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm
kidding it's a joke there's a joke for legal reasons we are
we do not enable we are not we are we do not enable scalping
at all we are we did not no vouches no vouches but like i
said we will be releasing more tickets for next week in
phase two if we manage to sell all the vip tickets do not
worry especially those people who aren't watching the vods
right now who are watching the vods um being like no i
missed up we are releasing more uh next week uh for uh for
those who missed out for vip vip the vip tickets will come
with autographed postcards for those who are wondering it
will be and it'll be like alternative art from um from the
uh there will it's an alternative art so basically it's like
a shiny pokemon type thing so vip take vip tickets will have
yeah so we'll have like alternative art that will be
autographed and it'll be an autographed postcard for
something I suggested.
I was like, I was willing to autograph it and I was, they're
like, are you sure?
Because I don't know how many VIP tickets there are.
And I was like, I was like, it's fine.
I can do it.
So now you have a pen, huh?
Yeah, well, I mean, I'm a VTuber, so it's like a digital
pen, you know?
It's a it's a, so you know.
But it's actually, it's a real market, guys.
It's a, it's not a digital it's a real but but it's because
it's because on that day on that day they're gonna give me a
they're gonna give me a mark i don't know where to find this
marker she be you know oh i give you a sharpie i'd be
helpful oh i got one on standby oh oh oh i oh my gosh sorry
my hand is my wrist is like i sprained my wrist so um i
can't do it yeah i can't write anything right now i'm so
sorry TV you know I was trying to save there was a burning
building on my walk to here for this news conference and
then like yeah so like I see there was a cat that jumped out
of the window and I had to you know as a hero I don't know
you saw the news earlier you know I was on the front page of
the newspaper and I managed to save the cat from the burning
building but because of that my wrist I actually sprained my
wrist so I can't write anything right now Yeah, what you
want.
I'll ask you in a week.
Yeah.
Don't worry.
I'll sign your cast in a week.
I'll buy a VIP ticket and get it.
Yeah.
So yeah.
Again, some people were still wondering, oh, the guest for a
leak.
Our concert is on.
day three on July 4th because it's also my birthday yeah
it's my birthday I'm actually 69 yeah yeah you're 67 I'm 69
so we're gonna be on day three if you are confused about
which day to get the tickets for we're gonna be day three
day one and Kisan and they also have their own very special
guests for day one.
But day three is Chibiana and we have around seven to eight
special guests for our concert.
So we're super excited.
You're going to want to be there day three.
I'm just going to say it.
There's a lot of cool stuff.
Yeah.
And also you guys might have noticed it is in the afternoon
because we wanted to make sure we know there is another
event going on on July 4th and we want to make sure have the
chance to be able to go to two concerts uh on that day so
there's no over you know you are not we're not forcing you
to pick and choose which concert to go to uh we made sure to
have it yeah to have it in the afternoon so you can make you
can if you're all going to another concert that's on that
day you'll be able to make it uh or like just leave like you
know you have to pick between anyone and you can support
everyone if you're looking to and and also that just means
Yeah, it's all concerts.
Just go to everything, you know?
Yeah.
I believe, yeah.
We believe in freedom.
USA.
Hamburger.
Hamburger country.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, my God.
Wow.
I can't, I'm so happy we're finally able to announce this,
Chibi.
I know.
We've been sitting on it for quite a while.
Yeah.
Like, I want to talk.
chat like what i've been up to and i like i'm just like i
can't say anything yeah i know it's just like i i haven't
been able to stream a lot uh for like like people they were
like whoa why do you have to do like like less than two hour
streams every day or like where's your schedule i was like
you don't understand we were both like trapped in work hell
we were so i was i was so tired i was working on this.
There was a choreo.
There was like less lessons and everything.
Like for me, this is my first time doing a full set list.
There's so many songs.
There's like at least 10 plus songs.
I can't keep track.
There's because it's a full set list and Chibi's also doing
her own little mini set list as well.
So there's me personally, I'll be there's so many songs i
never haven't been able to i i've been doing like mini set
list so this is my first time doing a full set list for this
concert so uh it's a lot of work and this is also chibi's
first time doing a 3d concert as well so she's learning a
lot dude it's my first time singing it's her third oh my god
this is like exclusive like it's good guys i'm kind of
nervous i it's my voice might crack or like i i might like
burp or fart i'm really nervous because when i get I get
gassy in both ends so I'm really nervous about oh my god for
free oh wait not for free because you gotta get a ticket if
you want it for the VIPs it's like did you be like all the
general admission please close your ears uh we're we don't
have a splash zone people burp so that's right fog up your
glasses in the front row oh yeah the front row too oh that's
right only if you're in the front row will you be able to
hear it uh
um but yeah uh so when also we just want to be sure you guys
know like uh the when we talked about the guests the seven
to eight guests uh uh it is unrelated to day one concert so
uh our guests are not mentioned at all yet so it's not it's
a secret until it's announced later i don't know when it's
announced because i don't know the guest announcement
schedule we're just here to announce this We don't know the
guest announcement schedule yet, so when it's announced, we
will let you guys know.
Whoa!
That's a preview.
That's a little... That's for the VIP.
Yeah, that's a sneak peek for her set list.
That's right.
That's one of my songs.
Yes, the guests are our mystery.
It's just for a population 10 minute long.
It's a bunch of people you might recognize.
A bunch of our friends in the VTubing community, a lot of
amazing singers, people who love this genre.
very nice speaking yeah yeah so uh so uh we're both so
excited and we're so thankful for our guests for saying yes
and joining us too uh you know the fact that they were
giving they gave up their time to be part of this concert
with us so we're very excited about that um um so there's a
lot of familiar faces you guys might recognize and like i
said some of these guests are singing more than one song so
they might be doing like two or three songs and uh so yeah
i'm trying to think about if i missed anything else what uh
is there anything else you want to say chibi oh it's so
freaking exciting i don't know it's so exciting oh my oh
yeah do you see the graphics they made for us i'll she can
show it too i downloaded it let's see we made like special
graphics for us so So there's I'll cover you up because it's
me So there's Mike Wazowski Yeah I'm gonna get Mike Wazowski
Real quick There's me We're at the Vermont Hollywood July
4th at 2 30 That's me And then there's And then This is
Cheapy one And I'll get Mike Wazowski here Okay Am I being
the same Yeah yeah There you are That's the wrong way, wrong
way.
That's the wrong way.
I'm trying to look at the logo.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Look at the logo.
Oh, look at that logo, guys.
It's so good.
Whoa.
Big fat head.
Oh my.
I'm trying to like remember if there's anything.
else if we're missing anything else about this uh about the
announcement um i'm trying to remember chibi is there
anything else i missed oh
yo it is a press conference we'll open up the table to the
chat to ask us questions now q a yeah q a q a q a it's like
a free panel Will Bandai be a guest if they want to it's
gonna be By oh wait, by what you don't need an anime expo
ticket by the way for those who are wondering you don't need
an animal Expo ticket to come to your concert.
You just need this ticket.
You just need a concert ticket Or buy the or if whenever the
streaming tickets go up whenever That is out That we're
still negotiating on You just need that.
Yeah, well there be food i think like for those who were at
the venue i saw people they were doing drinks and stuff i
think that's why it's also 18 plus because there's alcohol
i'm pretty sure so like you can get like there's a bar there
so you can get drinks and stuff i believe watch our concert
and then forget it you can come back you can like yeah you
can buy a streaming ticket and just be like just be like i
forgot what happened i have to get the streaming ticket my
singing might drive some people to drink so it's good that
that's there yeah yeah yeah you know they gotta take a shot
before uh they're like oh chibi's next guy take a shot real
quick uh i gotta pregame it yeah yeah yeah yeah i gotta
pregame it but yes don't worry if you cannot travel do not
worry we are currently working on streaming tickets right
now um so do not worry uh what would be the length of the
concert in time chibi did you know we're gonna wait actually
i don't even know the press releases out let me wait i was
like i gotta stop myself before no i can't i don't want to
get in trouble i know i'm about to leave the set list all
right oh my god no don't we are currently uh we have we
currently there is a billboard article about us well we're
like more like a side note because they're more focused on
day one but we're still on we are on a billboard article i
do not know if it tells us the the time the duration of
because it really depends because you know we're we're
yappers chibi and i are yappers and stuff so yeah we don't
know how we're like we take up what if we're when we're
doing mc we take up like 20 minutes and we're just like like
stop this music guys let's host a podcast right now yeah
like we're intermission time guys and then we just start we
just stop the music and we just sit there and just yap for
like 30 minutes it won't even be on screen to you it's like
just a black screen and you just hear our voices yapping
What's the deal with...
Airplane food!
Yeah, what's up with airplane food, guys?
Yeah, we take like a break where we just hop on Marvel
Rivals.
Yeah, yeah, again.
Or Overwatch.
We put up Overwatch and we just play Overwatch on the
screen.
Yeah, that's actually sick.
Bro, I actually did that for my first concert.
The Phantom Thief concert with Mint.
That's so funny.
We just, just before, we're like, that's right, guys.
Because, like, it was, like, the intro.
But, like, this is what you've been waiting for.
and that booted up Marvel Rivalis and just played like one
game before we started the concert.
We could do that as an intermission.
We're like, all right, guys, intermission time.
Watch us play Overwatch for 30 minutes.
So that's punishment.
No wonder there's an alcohol, like a bar.
There's a, but it all just goes to, yeah, but then that's
good.
That's good for the bar, you know?
Business will go up.
Yeah.
We're helping, we're supporting local businesses here.
Look at that.
We're such good people.
We're role models.
Yeah, we really are.
But yeah, here's the Billboard article, by the way.
I had to make sure I wasn't leaking the press release.
I wasn't sure.
I wasn't sure the Billboard article was out already.
Because we have to sync with the press release, too.
But yeah.
Wait, yeah, I'm in it.
Look at that.
Well, you have to scroll down, but I'm in it.
The night... She's there.
Wait, am I...
Yeah, day three will be a match and a performance of Doki
Doki Rewind Time.
A concert co-produced, created, and headlined by VTuber Doki
Bird.
Wow!
That's me!
Doki Bird spotted.
Oh, my God.
Spread the word, guys.
Let everyone know about this kind of...
I didn't think I'd be doing another, I mean, to be honest,
it's sort of tradition for me now, Chibi.
I think, like, I did a concert last year at Anime Expo, and
then the year before that, I did the Phantom Thief.
I never thought I would, like, have a full set list, because
that's a lot of work.
It's awesome, but you're killing it, and, dude, the songs
are so good, and it's, dude, I don't think, I don't think
your community is ready.
I don't think either of our community is ready.
It's so sick.
Oh, my God.
The I think the set list alone I'm really proud of our set
list.
In general GV like I'm so proud of it.
I know it's not like Calm stuff.
You have the hype stuff.
You have the dance stuff.
It's perfect.
You have memes.
It has like something for everyone.
Yeah it's just It's yeah and it's like all these songs that
You've listened to before as well And something you don't
like I said you don't normally see in a YouTuber concert too
and And it's It's very exciting I'm super excited for it.
Oh my gosh.
It's definitely crazy.
It's freaking epic.
It's awesome.
It's pogger.
Oh.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe it's finally out, too.
I can't believe you can finally talk about it.
I know.
I literally caught myself almost talking about it.
And I'd go, nothing.
I did nothing.
Nothing's going on.
I just sat at home.
I did not do anything.
We're just...
Yeah, I was they're like what are you doing?
Why did you have to travel?
I was like you'll all find out soon on Tuesday Tuesday will
find out I was like I kept telling them I was like I'm so
tired guys I'm so I'm like there's no there's I'm still in
the tunnel of work.
There's so much stuff to do It was a lot like compared to
the others concerts.
This has to be the hardest thing I've like compared to every
project I've done this has to be a the hardest thing I've
ever done because like I was basically I basically had to
like yeah it's gonna be so awesome like I the I think the
amount of like blood sweat and tears you put into it is so
freaking obvious and I think people are really gonna love it
yeah I I'm I'm I'm I cannot wait to like just I can't wait
to see the venue you know in person yeah yeah I cannot wait
to see the venue in person and like it is crazy because like
uh for those who are wondering like why this was the hardest
like i've done other concert before i had to like basically
direction wise like what each song's direction was gonna be
and how how like the choreo how like because i wanted like
special choreo for some of these songs um because i wanted
to fit like for some of the songs i wanted to fit the vibe
of what the concert was gonna be like some like you know i'm
seeing there's a song that's like punk rock there's a song
that's like uh skater rock stuff like that and I wanted like
choreo to match that type of vibe so like the like how you
perform it and everything so a lot of it was very planned
meticulously in terms of like how how I wanted it to go like
directing all of it and like co-producing stuff like that
and then there's like you know figuring the set list and
also the the vibe of everything the uh and uh And like, just
like how production-wise of everything was supposed to go.
So it was a lot of work.
I was, I had a breakdown, maybe multiple breakdowns over
this.
You guys don't even know how hard she's been working.
Like, when I say she's working hard, she's like, it's like a
full-time, like over time.
She's working so freaking hard.
There would be like, I would wake up and there would be like
10 plus messages about this concert.
And I was just like, ugh.
it's like it was crazy it was so crazy and like you know um
i really appreciate you tv too for working so hard with like
everything that was going on as well and i was so scared
just want to do this because i think you're awesome i i
really do feel like no matter what we do it'll be fun
because we're like actual we're friends so like i think uh i
i think everything you put into it and i'm very new to
everything but i really did my best and i think because of
your guidance and everything.
I think like just the fact that we're two friends doing
something fun together is what's gonna make it so worth the
time all the effort you put into it.
And I think all the effort you put into it too.
Because I got really worried for you.
I'm okay.
So worried for it.
Well there was a point where like basically I was getting
strep throat.
Like it was like the pain of strep throat like every other
day.
And it just constantly get worse where like I couldn't even
eat without like gagging it.
Holy fuck.
Yeah.
It was so bad.
But you know what?
You learned If you stop pushing yourself hard you start to
get better.
I startedку like one hour, two hour streams.
I was like, wow the pain's almost gone.
Who would have thought?
And I had no pain.
Whoa, who would have thought?
No, forget streaming for six hours and screaming would fix
the problem.
So I'm much better.
And I took Doki's advice and I've been taking it much
slower.
And who would have guessed I'm much better.
Who would have guessed?
Yeah, who would have guessed you can recover a lot faster if
you don't, if you like chill a little bit.
So what if those?
she also worked very hard also this is our first concert
this is our first 3d concert as well like oh my gosh during
like the demo session like when we're like practicing and
like demoing some stuff we're like figuring out stuff it's
so funny seeing like i we will say like it it's not the her
3d model is tiny
like compared you would see the height different between me
and her it's it's so funny it's like like like when I see
her like dancing next to me it's it's it's it's pretty it's
like that cat you know it's like the guy watching the cat
dance yeah yeah it's sort of like that it's sort of like
that yeah yeah we I was watching the preview of like while
we were like demoing stuff to make like just to demo stuff
demoing the motion capture and one third the height of It
Guys I'm I'm helping Donkey feel more masculine She looks so
muscular next to me You know kick the baby Like it's like
don't kick the baby You know like the kick the baby Is like
don't kick the baby So I'm gonna dance and then I'm gonna
dance And then my foot would be like Poop I'd like punch it
So awesome if you could like kick me And then like we throw
like A stuffed animal under the trap Oh my god like punch
you and it's like catch her and then like someone chucks one
of your one of your youtube dolls into the crown and oh my
god you know like those t-shirt cannons you look we can free
the t-shirt cannon and then launch you out of the t-shirt
cannon in the middle of the song oh my god you should we
should we should tell the producer we should tell the the
staff that like we can we have like one of the band members
just just uh bring out one of the plushies and then chuck
you in oh that could surfing she can start crowd surfing
Shove it in the pocket So we're going to steal it We gotta
put it on a string So we can yank it back Yeah There's like
a fishing Like a fishing line And you're like Hey Hey Hey
Hey Hey Hey YouTube Hey Y 'all return that What are you guys
doing You're biting it The chibi cannon Instead of t-shirts
Is just It's just a chibi cannon Sam is so freaking funny Oh
my god I'm Write this down.
Write this down.
What's cool about, like, Doki doing everything is, I think,
every silly idea she has, we're like, wait, we can do that.
Oh, yeah, that's true.
I was like, can we...
Yeah, we'd be like, wait, we can actually make this happen.
See, we're still brainstorming.
We're still trying to improve this.
We're still adding more to it and everything.
Yeah, we're planning the concert live.
We still have three more months, guys.
We still have...
We still have three more months.
Guys, give us ideas so we can steal them.
can add them into the costume as well we'll make your
money's worth you know we're gonna yeah yeah yeah we're
making your money's worth lawsuit incoming from all the
injuries she causes with her giant head yeah but her head
but her head is filled with helium so like what damages you
know it's like it's like a squeaky toy hit it's like a light
yeah yeah like those like always like those squeaky mallets
it's like lightweight yeah yeah it'll just deflect off back
onto the stage It's perfect for crowd search.
You'll be fine.
If anything, like, I'd be surprised if the Chibi plushie
survives.
I mean, it just pops.
Oh, yeah, it's like a balloon.
Yeah, it pop.
It deflates.
The plushie just deflates.
It's going to come back with a dent.
You're like, somehow the stuffing is missing.
Like, someone pulled out the stuffing in the head and we're
like, we're not burnt out with a cigarette.
It's a real, gosh, it's a real punk rock concy.
yeah you're not supposed to smoke inside though but like oh
my god i hope i see you know like that infamous like the
goth dance like the yes with the arms yeah i hope someone
yes bro if anyone does that at the concert like you guys
should come in cosplay but like early 2000s oh y2k oh yeah
yeah yeah have like 80 bracelets on one arm yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah like like raccoon tail in your hair Like all that.
Oh my god.
Make sure you have all the accessories the crosses the The
what are those like the spiked bracelet?
That would actually be cool, but you don't have to you don't
have to though guys, you don't have you want to be you don't
No, no, no, no, it's not bad.
All the goth makeup too like the crying mascara and
everything like yeah, yeah, yeah, the really oh, yeah the
droopy pants with too many pockets yes yes and make sure you
dye your hair like you have like the uh the emo hair you
know like the liberty spike the emo hair where one covers
one eye and then there's some and then like a little bit
black dye on the hair and everything go to hot topic i make
sure you stop by hot topic before you go to the concert oh
yeah that's actually you might out log us You guys are
look-maxing.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
You guys might actually, like, have better outfits than us
at the concert.
Physically cringey.
That was the fashion back then.
What do you mean?
We were...
Yeah, I think that stuff looks cool.
Like, anytime I see someone who's gothic, I'm like, oh, my
God, they're so cool.
They look so awesome.
And those people dress gothic.
It was, like, the nicest people ever.
Every time they're so sweet.
pretty sick though like i think like the fashion just goes
hard yeah in general yeah if you walk it rattles and clinks
that means you're cool you got like a lot of accessories oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm i'm awesome oh but yeah like you
guys said i'm i'm just excited i know i keep saying that but
it's just there's so much love being put um on this concert
by the way the tickets were Originally, I don't know if you
saw it, but she apparently originally the tickets were
supposed to be up sooner or earlier than like our
announcement and I was like, wait, because then we're like,
wait, no, it's going to support us.
No, we have to, no.
And then we managed to, luckily, we managed to make it to
where the tickets go up on four.
So then, so then, you know, it's more like it's equal.
Everyone.
So then like when we announced it, they're like, they can
start up now.
I was so worried it was spoiled the surprise Because it was
going to go public like 15 minutes earlier So I was like
really nervous that it was going to spoil the surprise So
luckily the concert people caught it in time Because there
was like a caught in time And we were able to get it
scheduled at 4 instead So but for those who are scared that
tickets are going to be sold out I would be very I would
honestly for me, Chibi Like I would be I would cry we sold
out but that would that would be like so crazy i i don't
even this like my first time doing anything this big and the
fact that there's already so much support for it i don't
know i really appreciate this all the support guys but very
very crazy but you if if somehow the tickets do sell out
before the week ends do not worry do not worry because on
tuesday we are releasing more tickets for those who are who
might have watched the VOD late who you know time zones for
the announcement had to save up maybe that was like yeah
yeah so another we're gonna have phase two phase two of uh
more concert tickets being released for especially for VIP
hopefully we can have the the screen the online ones for you
guys yeah hopefully we're trying our best we're trying yeah
we've been working on it really hard because that was
traveling is so expensive yeah yeah so don't worry about it
if you can't if you can't like get there or anything i
totally understand california is crazy oh yeah yeah
especially everything's going on right now as well uh so we
do understand so we're trying really hard to make sure it's
more accessible to everybody but oh yeah let me remake the
links for b1.2s uh concert because i just posted the link
with no context uh i was like guys it's still twice our
picture of my house now yeah click this link i'm my ip in
the chat click this link it's my it's my little mixtape that
i made like it's my mix tape uh all right what do you say uh
let's see throw back oh wait 3d concert would she be uh on
july 4th all right i think that's all i have to do that 3d
concert would she be on july 4th there you go yay it's
official now awesome yeah it's like click this link it's not
it's not uh malware i swear to go if she starts like going
really loud don't worry about it there's no bitcoin being
mine yeah please download this i'm me and chibi are making a
new indie game right now and we're looking for playtester
minecraft mod and i'm looking for someone to uh install it
can you click on this link and install this mod pack for me
and just to try it out uh why did that control panel open
what's happening oh yeah wait why is that why was there a
black browser that popped in and out uh then commands are
being entered right now uh my bitcoin is gone now no no it's
just a little glitch guys if any of your bitcoin suddenly
disappears it's just whoa just a little error i'm in a
pattern she's telling the truth guys click that link click
that link oh i wait i forgot to say 3d i forgot it's day
three because like there's three days ours is day three by
the way be like don't be if you're like you bought day one
i'm sorry That's, ours are day three.
That's not the day one.
You got multiple days to go to now.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Now you can have two days to go to.
Ours is the one in the afternoon.
Yeah, yeah.
Ours is the afternoon on day three.
July 4th.
On day three for July 4th.
All right, let me write that.
Let me see.
Okay, so if you buy day one, you won't have access to day
three.
So make sure you buy the right day.
And I'll also put it on the screen too.
GB and I are doing...
Someone just said, why is my bank calling me?
Yeah, so I was like, why is my GPU at 100%?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
A 3D concert on July 4th.
your tickets now click on link not malware i'll write not
malware it's just in case people
it's legal so legally we're protected you know like we said
it wasn't malware but if it is somehow you did accidentally
clicked a link that did lead to malware legally it's not our
fault we said it wasn't we we said it wasn't malware so
we're legally protected uh
we're innocent here i look at it's not above me look at it
wow i also like that i wrote it in common sans so it brings
legitimacy to my statement so it's definitely not malware
Yeah, that's definitely real.
It's not written by an AI.
We're not AI.
Have you played Pregmata yet?
No, but I want to.
It's really fun.
The clips on Twitter have been melting my heart.
It's so freaking cute.
It's cute.
Well, I don't care about the chat.
What?
Because, because why should I care about that chat when I
have you TV?
Oh, you know, you know, exactly.
Exactly.
I matter.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yes.
I think the gunplay is really, the mechanics are really fun
in general.
Any of the gameplay except the really cute clips and that's
already sold me on it.
Oh my, I think you would really enjoy the gameplay.
Because like when I was watching the trailers for the game,
it, for me it didn't like sell me on the game.
Because I just, because it was a new IP too by Capcom.
So like Capcom hasn't really had a new IP in a long ass
time.
So like for me it wasn't like super good.
super solid on it at first.
And then, but then, like, you have to, it's like, it's more
of a type, like, when you play it, you realize how much fun
it is.
I'm excited.
I really do have to play it.
Yeah, yeah.
I highly recommend it.
Yeah.
Like, I really like the art, and the main character's design
is, like, sick.
I think he looks really cool.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I love that his name is Hugh, because, like...
He's his last name, Janus?
He was like, yeah.
I was like, oh, my God, he's a Hugh Miss.
All right.
Hugh, Janus!
No!
Yeah, but it definitely, you definitely try.
Like I, I was, uh, my next stream was supposed to be, you
know that mouse PI game?
The, yes, yes, it just came out.
I was, I was planning on playing that on what day is it?
Tuesday.
I was planning on playing that on Thursday, but then like.
Can I give you a game I want you to play?
Oh, what, what is it?
Have you played trees hate you yet?
Oh, I saw clips about it.
I thought it was, how long is it?
It's like 30 minutes, 40 minutes.
It's the best rage bait game I've ever played.
Yeah, it reminded me of the Mario.
one like that's what yeah yeah it's so good it's just the
demo though so if you want to wait for the full one yeah i
but i i know i was thinking about like waiting for the full
demo like for the full one because i was like oh the demo
must be like really short or something and then but then
like apparently it's gonna take like two years or i was like
i'm not like one to two years i think the dev was like yeah
i'm planning on making this game but um it's gonna take me
like one to make this game and i was like i don't like a
single person making it or like a very small team that's
impressive yeah because it's one apparently the the demo
itself was made by one guy when will it actually kind of
cool i didn't know that okay apparently i think it's the
first rage game i've like played that like is actually good
and funny most of the time they just piss me off i'm like
mother yeah because you don't expect it you know it's like
which tree which tree is gonna get me Oh, it's like that
it's like that Japanese game the agree one you play that one
which one the agree Yeah, yeah, that's what it reminded me
of You know how like you're at the real one when you
actually get to the real game when it starts Um, and then
you have yeah, have you ever went through the actual trials?
I never beat it I hate that game Wait, did you even get to
the end of I I did, and I died instantly.
I do not want to talk about my shortcomings.
I am so pissed off at that game.
Okay, I read.
We are working on streaming tickets.
I just remembered to put that on here, too.
People were wondering, we are working on streaming tickets.
Yay.
All right.
There we go.
We'll put it on top of you, too.
So people will have to.
read this?
Well, my head is kind of like, I've always said, like, I'll
put it as like an advertising thing.
Oh, yeah, yeah, like the advertising on your forehead.
Oh, wait, go bald!
Yes.
Go bald right now.
Oh, it doesn't fit.
No, it doesn't fit.
Your head, you gotta be you gotta have a toggle where like
your head just starts expanding the more, so then you can
sell advertising space on it.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, you should like expand your... That is too big
for my fat head.
Yeah, yeah, it has to be longer.
It's like Jimmy Neutron type head, you know?
Yeah, like, it's gotta be like, not like, you know, like,
how in America, how we teach how to fold paper, it's hot dog
style, and yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's my head's gotta be hot dog style.
Oh my god, it's gonna be Mega Man style.
Mega Mind is my favorite movie of all time.
I love Mega Mind.
I actually own the I own a special edition DVD set with the
behind the scenes and bloopers and animation stuff.
That's so cool!
I had it pirated from my uncle, so I never had it again.
Oh my god, Code Leocco head style.
Yeah, you should get a Code Leocco.
Have you ever seen Code Leocco with a giant ass for it?
Wait, look.
Had you know what Code Leocco is?
No, Code Leocco.
I do know what this is, you motherfucker.
Delete that, say in that person.
I have seen that.
I didn't know the name of it.
She booed him for saying the truth.
Get him up.
Mods.
Seize him.
Oh, I uh Oh Oh, yeah, I forgot about the Q&A Sorry, back to
the Q&A portion We're like Let's open up the floor to the Q
It's like the reporters Now reporters, you can ask your
questions Yes Go pick and choose Alright, guys Any questions
Any questions?
I'm so jealous of NA bros.
I'm sorry.
It's really hard, especially, like, concert, like, the
concert organizers we were working on.
They are also NA-based as well.
But maybe in future, I do would love to do concerts outside
of NA.
So, maybe next year.
But, this is all new to us, new to Chibi, and also still new
to me.
So, you know, every event, I learn more about it, and learn
more on how to uh organize these types of events and stuff
uh you don't really realize how much work goes into it like
i've never been involved with something like this and i like
seeing doky do every i'm like i annoy like it really is like
a like a movie or like an art performance like everything is
thought through and it's really really impressive to see
like everyone come together it's cool yeah there's a i'm so
excited oh man there's a lot of people working working very
hard on this uh and we can't wait we really can't wait for
you guys to experience all the hard work that everybody uh
uh did on this concert all right let's see if on your right
streaming tickets are being worked on and the guests are not
announced yet they're yeah surprise we're gonna be
announcing them down the line i'm just gonna say they're
really cool and you're not ready yet they're awesome all
right new pin so it gets, so it tells everything because I
know like some of you guys cannot travel and we're working
very hard on making sure that it will be accessible to
everybody.
Like that's one thing that we really, really want for this
concert, for those who can't travel in this economy.
Someone asked for a hint on one of the merch items.
One of the merch items?
Oh, I did say earlier uh so the hint that i mentioned
earlier i'll mention again that it's not your conventional
vtuber merch concert merch type deal it's not your
conventional vtuber concert merch we are there's some
specialty items in there that are very on theme to what uh
to what like n a to n a concert to like an n a concert like
especially like related to uh to the theme up this concert.
That's all I'll say.
Uh, so it's very different from a usual VTuber concert
merch.
Yeah, like something different you can keep.
Like, I feel like, uh, it's still, like, definitely, like, a
concert, but in, like, VTuber themed, but it's something I
feel like, like, a lot of stuff anyone could enjoy.
And also, it's just really unique to have on a shelf or
wherever you display it.
It's, like, it'll be a very good memory, because it's very,
very distinct and very cool.
Yeah, yeah, it's very, very, something something on theme to
it and someone said will it be online yes we will have
online merch and that will be late that more information
about that later but there will be online merch for those
who cannot make it to the venue we'll have merch at venue
and then merch online as well all right any other questions
any other questions concerns all of this will be on the quiz
yeah yeah yeah Remember to study up.
Remember to study up on the exam.
Like I said, phase two of the tickets.
If VIP tickets are sold out or will be sold out by the end
of the week, we have phase two for next Tuesday at 4 p.m.
PST.
We are announcing guests.
We just, she and I don't know the schedule of the guest
announcements, but they will be announced at a later time.
And like I said, there's a lot of guests to announce.
And there are very familiar faces in the VTuber community.
So, yeah, that's really basically...
Basically, that's the info that we can share regarding
guests.
What has been your favorite part?
Preparing this, the theme.
Just doing the theme for this.
Like, coming up with a theme.
And also, like, just doing...
Preparing the set list.
Okay, Chibi might recall this, but we're both freaking out
about the set list because we didn't realize about like
songwrites and stuff.
Because we, we're like, we want to do some really, really
silly songs too.
Because the last time I did a concert, we didn't have to
worry too much about it.
So like we could pick whatever song, you know.
I did Han Solo because I didn't have to worry about like
songwrites in terms of like, especially...
putting it online so i was just like i want to do han solo
and then i did it like because we didn't really sound like
strict this is a great idea no this is a great idea nope
nope nope because we are because we wanted to do streaming
tickets yeah so if it was a concert like just a concert the
live like just the venue was like just on the venue we could
do whatever the fuck we want like because it's just it's a
lot like songwrites like on especially in This is the thing
about NA as well, for those who don't know.
If you're performing a concert in NA, you don't really have
to worry about like copyright slash song rights if you're
covering a song as a concert because there's not streaming
tickets like worldwide as well.
So because we really wanted to try and make streaming
tickets work.
Like I said, it's still negotiating and we're still being
worked on.
We had to be more strict with what song we could sing and
what song we could pick.
so we're trying to that's why we were trying really really
hard uh on trying to make sure it's accessible to everybody
so we picked songs that got cleared we like we would send we
i made a john list chibi i saw the list it was like pages
long of all these songs and then one third of it got
approved thank you like i will say even through all of the
the set list like having like fine do think like out of all
of the hurdles the ones we ended up with are so perfect i
would pick them yeah they're so good they're so funny it's
good yeah it's so the set list like we the songs that got
cleared um that got cleared for us to perform it's a good
set list what we picked in the end was really it's just you
know there are songs that you have all sang along to
basically Like, you've sang along to the song.
You've heard this on the radio before.
They're all good vibes and all of that.
Yeah, we sing along.
Yeah, yeah.
Honestly, we encourage.
We encourage you guys.
If you guys know the song, sing along to it if you want to.
Like, because we want to make it a concert, you know.
Like, you know, you ever been to a concert?
You know, Coachella.
Literally Coachella.
Everyone's singing along in Coachella when Justin Bieber
came out.
And me like, baby, baby.
I will say there's no baby.
I just...
Wait, I thought one of us was pregnant.
Congratulations on boy, I will say no Justin Bieber because
if anyone Justin Bieber was not cleared We're sorry.
We're sorry to all the believers out there like We could not
make Justin Bieber.
I was like, thank you We couldn't we couldn't get any get
any Justin Bieber songs approved for the set list
oh yeah for those who didn't know Justin Bieber actually
does not own his catalog he like sold his music rights to
like a music company yeah so like I think he got like I
don't remember how much he made off of it but it was why
like I don't know did you saw the viral clip of the
Coachella stuff when yes where he's not even trying and then
he locks the freaking yeah yeah so like you know how yeah he
brought up his Mac or whatever and he started like YouTubing
songs off of his off of doing a karaoke with himself yeah
the reason why he did that is because he didn't own any of
the rights to his old songs so the only way he could sing
his song like because he and he didn't want to pay the the
record company for singing it at Coachella so he literally
did a karaoke session with himself just so he could sing his
old catalog at Coachella like that was just like I was like,
yeah, that's so smart.
He got paid $10 million, by the way.
He's like, what?
Yeah, he is the most expensive Coachella guest ever.
And he's like, he did a karaoke on a laptop.
Yeah, and he did a karaoke.
What the frick?
He actually, it was actually an unarchived karaoke because
apparently the Coachella videos, they're supposed to be
unlisted.
They are supposed to be privated after a week or so.
So it's literally an unarchived karaoke with himself.
like what the but like i said the one thing i can say about
our set list is that we have no justin beaver songs they
were not approved but we weren't given a choice we were
given a choice on singing songs that weren't approved um for
streaming but we just had to remove it during the streaming
session the people who bought streaming tickets just
wouldn't be able to want everyone to have the equal
experience.
Yeah, the full experience of the concert.
So we make, because like, they're like, oh, if you really
want to sing this song, you can.
It just has to be, we just have to cut that from the
streaming tickets.
So, because we didn't Yeah, that's not fun.
We want everyone to have an equal experience.
So we make sure to choose a set list that can be both live
and like at the venue and also whenever the negotiations for
streaming stuff, we're still working on it.
Like, we want to make sure that everybody gets the same
equal experience for this concert.
Yeah.
It's really fun.
I think that's, like I said, I think that was the most fun
for all of it.
Just being able to work on this theme in general because you
don't see that in VTuber concerts and just VTuber music too.
Like, I remember, I'll keep TV.
I didn't know you saw it there.
I was just like, I just, I'm sorry.
I was just like, I just don't want to sing a Japanese song
right now.
I just want to sing all in English.
I was like, I would punch, I would punch.
Butcher it!
Like, there's so many bangers, but it'd be really bad.
Yeah, I'm so bad at pronouncing Japanese words, too.
So I was just like, I want my concert to be full English,
because I was just like, I...
There's so many songs.
And it's so...
And there's a lot of bangers, though, that, like, people can
perform that kind of music.
And it's, like, so awesome, because everyone's going to know
every song.
Yeah, yeah.
It's just going to be so cool.
Oh, there is foreign language.
It's like, it's like part of the, there's some songs that
might have like maybe one or two lines of a foreign language
in there.
Yeah, maybe it's one, a song that Chibi and I have together.
It's like, disposito, but...
That was beautiful, guys.
That's a pastry concert.
Did you like that?
Click the link And then you can hear us sing the full song
That's mine Oh my god Okay Oh okay I will say there was a
song that we really wanted to do as a duet But we couldn't
get the song rights clear for it Oh my god it was perfect It
was so It was We were so excited for that I'll say because
it's not in the set list It was Living the vita loca With
pus and boots and dog The pus and boots Booth's donkey
version.
So perfect.
It would have been perfect for us.
Yeah.
I know.
But I know it's, I think we got something.
The replacement for that is better.
And we'll just say the place, the replacement for it is
better than the Shrek one.
Uh, it is so good.
You guys are like, no, what a loss.
but no you don't know the replacement is so much better we
we managed to find an even better song the latin community
gosh oh oh don't worry latin american community
don't worry
It's almost like it's Dragon Ball.
Oh my god.
Yeah, Chibi's got you.
She's got you.
Oh my god, speak Spanish to them, Chibi.
Okay.
Ah, tu, a yo, amigo, siempre.
What do you say?
Culo, gorda.
Tu yo, titas, explosion.
Explosion?
Two is you.
And then something, something, explosion.
Yes.
Titas explosion.
Are you saying slurs?
Are you?
I gotta go, guys.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, how do you say it?
buy our tickets in Español.
Oh, uh, Puta Du Dinero Vamos!
I, for some reason, I don't believe you.
Because the first word you said was Puta.
So, I said put your money in my butt.
Let's go.
My Spanish is like, like Madeline's.
I only know how the words are like sticking together.
It's random words.
It's like, I know what money is.
I know how I'm proud to say but.
And I know how to say chits or bitch.
Do you know?
Do you want to learn Spanish?
Sure.
As long as you can't.
No puta.
Okay.
No, no puta.
Um.
Say I.
Yo soy.
Okay.
Say the full sentence.
You.
Yo soy poyo.
You're so lucky.
I don't know.
any of those words right now.
You're so- Why are people saying chibi?
It's so bad!
Yo soy poyo!
Yo soy poyo.
Yo soy.
Like Kirby.
Poyo.
It means I am chicken.
Yo soy poyo.
Yo.
Eya era poyo.
You are chicken.
And what are you?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You say, puta gorda, buenos dias.
I'll Google how to say click that link in Spanish.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I say click that link in Spanish.
Okay.
I'm gonna say, okay.
Click the link to buy concert tickets.
All right, I got this.
This is gonna be fluent, guys.
Okay, okay.
Oh, pick, that sounds hard.
Yes.
Yeah,
buy our tickets.
I didn't know when it ended.
I was like, oh, wow, that's a...
I did my best.
I was like, that's a long sentence for buy our tickets.
I was like, guys, yes, please support.
Support Chibi and I on the Doki Doki rewind time for some
nice throwback, nostalgic, from the 2000s to the 2010s.
A lot of our, I mean, I think majority, all our songs.
All the songs we picked, the 2000s, the 2010s, a lot of
classics, a lot of great songs to sing along too.
We do have VIP tickets, like I said, we're doing Phase 2
next Tuesday.
So you guys, VIP tickets do sell out by the end of the week.
Do not worry, next Tuesday, we do have more tickets that
will be coming out around 4 p.m.
PST.
for the support.
Remember to buy, it's day three, by the way.
It's day three.
Our concert is day three on July 4th.
There is day one and day two, but our concert is day three.
If you want to support the other guests, we'll support
Matara, Kisan, and Lily.
They are on day one.
They also have all their special guests, too, and we have
our own special guests as well.
Is there anything else I'm missing, Chiefy?
There's nothing.
Check it out.
Check it out, guys.
We are working on streaming tickets for those who won't be
able to travel please look forward to any announcements
about that in the future thank you everybody for coming
coming to our press conference we're so excited about our 3D
concert together we'll see you guys next time everybody
thank you for all the support guys thank you guys if your
friends showed around yeah yeah if they're going to anime
expo send them this link there's a lot people going to anime
expo surely someone you know will be going there and send
them this link and be like that's gonna be so fun oh my god
bring your parents bring your fiance bring your
mother-in-law oh my god bring your dog dressing him up in
the emo outfit oh my god emo dog if it's like a poodle like
give him the the hair oh my god like shave yeah yeah anyway
guys thank you all for coming.
Chiba and I are going to head out.
Chiba's got rest.
She just came back.
You were on another stream too earlier.
You were like playing.
Oh yeah, you must be so tired too.
I'm going to die.
I'm okay.
I just have a lot of editing to do.
Alright.
Thank you all for the support.
We really appreciate it guys.
We're so excited to see all of you on see you guys on July
4th.
I'm celebrating my birthday with all of you guys too.
It's going to be so I'm so used to celebrate my birthday
with Chibi as well.
Yeah.
I thought like when, also I want to add more thing, one more
thing, when my manager was the one that helped, was the one
that reached out because like he really wanted to, you know,
have another concert experience for me.
He reached out to fantastic reality pitching this idea.
And then when we were saying like, who do we want to be like
the special, like the special guests with Doki and we were
like we wanted Chibi Doki to join in as my special guest and
then I'm really honored that you'd want to do it with me
yeah and it was like very very sweet and then we were like
Doki you know like Doki Doki you know like uh being able to
do this together with Chibi Doki uh for this concert it's
gonna be so fun and I'm very excited to show you guys
everything that we've been working super hard on um and yeah
really thank you to Chibi for like you know wanting to do
this with me too uh because we i would have done this for
half of mcchicken bro i just wanted to be fun with you
because you're cool i like hanging out with you and i like
hanging out this is why i won the custody battle tv now say
goodbye to your mom you're never seeing her again oh oh
that's true that's true you do get two christmases and like
and you can ask for like you know a little bit of money
right and yeah and then you can go faster yeah yeah yeah
yeah you can see yeah exactly and then we split the money
off with the money ask remember to ask paul for like a
christmas bonus too you know i'll i'll call you dad if you
give me 500 yeah exactly and then we'll use the 500 to go to
disneyland together
hey we're gonna be in california let's go yes exactly we can
go to disneyland
Let's go!
I was like, I'm trying to remember.
I remember like I was like looking up like places to go in
LA.
Like in LA, like what are some like gothic, like goth emo
stuff you can do.
And like, like you have punk stuff to do as well.
Yeah.
Oh, it's giving me like some nice father-daughter bonding
time.
There was like a, I'm trying to remember that place because
I was like, oh my God, it's one hour away from LA.
But I don't remember what it was.
Oh my god.
I mean, so I could find it on my, like, on my...
There was a Breaking Bad, like, food truck or something.
Oh my god, there's a Breaking Bad.
Sorry, I was, like, looking.
I see if I can find it on my history.
Because I was, like, actually, I was searching up some
places for something.
I'm trying to remember what it was.
Because I was like, oh, it's only an hour away from LA.
But what was it?
I didn't write it down.
What was this place?
We have time.
It's true.
We do have time.
Anyway, guys, thank you all for the support.
We really...
We're so excited to announce who the guests are in the
future.
So, really looking forward to all the announcements leading
up to this concert.
We're going to see you guys in three months.
In three months.
The band is live.
Remember, it's a live band, everybody.
So, it's going to go very hard.
Anyways, Chibi and I are going to head out now.
Thank you, everybody, for coming.
Bye, guys.
Thank you for listening.
Yeah, thank you.
Thank you to Cheeby for, you know, stopping by this channel
after her stream, too, right after her stream.
So, too, shout out to Cheeby for stopping by.
No problem, Moe.
I have fun hanging out.
And, yeah.
Anyway, guys, we'll see you guys later, everybody, next
time.
Bye, guys.
Bye, everybody.
Bye, bye.